let's take a closer look at gold now
we're back again with that in unfished
know from the german institute for
economic research is this a good time to
buy gold would you buy it I would be
cautious actually I think if
institutional investors are hesitant to
buy gold I wouldn't do it as a private
investor because I think they are better
informed than I am so who exactly is to
blame for this rapid drop in the gold
price well i think it was triggered in
fact by a cell of the superior tech
national bank but i think the story
underlying the decline is bigger in the
sense that what we had over the last 10
years was a bubble in the gold prices
and this needs to be corrected we had
increases of gold prices but around
twenty percent for the last ten years
and that's obviously much more than
other any other prices actually
increased over the last ten years and we
need some correction in this market so
none of the other factors that are also
talked about like weak data in China or
the u.s. monetary policy are really to
blame but it is just a sort of normal
consolidation you say it's hard to say
of course if real economic developments
are weak the demand for gold is weak and
this can push down prices as all prices
are also dependent on real economic
developments but I think it's more to
the story to the to the price of gold
it's what we've seen over the last 10
years was unusual and very unnormal and
we have a correction in that regard it's
hard to say how far down it goes
actually but it seems plausible to me
that we have a gold price below 1000
euro towards the end of this year okay
is this actually a bad thing long-term
the price of gold is going down it's
actually it's a bad thing for investors
in gold but it's not necessarily a bad
thing for the for the world in the sense
that the week gold prices could actually
signal to us that financial markets are
less nervous anymore because in the end
the price for gold was at least in part
high because financial markets used gold
as a safe haven used gold to as a
seemingly safe investment and now there
is not having that anymore it looks like
the financial markets are improving okay
well that's a quite optimistic that
inefficient thank you very much for
joining us today thank you
you